how was governor desantis relationship
with anthony fauci
are they like did he go to dinner
together do they text each other do they
play scrabble i'm just curious
gotta be kidding so he
um
he has said that fauci has
been the most destructive influence on
our country during this
throughout the pandemic frankly and
actually about a week ago it's funny you
should ask a week ago his campaign the
desantis's campaign released um they put
out merchandise all the time that you
can buy to support the game they
released a pair of flip-flops that are
fouchy flip-flops because he flip-flops
on so many things and then like he had
that's not a new thing the flip-flops
have been out there i think uh george
bush almost got hit by a flip-flop at
that point yeah
but you can see them and so they're
pretty fun and then like earlier this
summer he had a beer koozie that said
don't fouchy my florida
so there you go so it says pound sand
falchi like so you could see
that um
i wouldn't say they have a good
relationship but why should they because
fauci has been fighting florida every
step of the way he's been he was against
reopening he was against opening beaches
and we know beaches are not dangerous in
terms of its spread let me let me ask
you if desantis was president today like
maybe you guys have had the discussion
he's a strong leader how we how would he
have handled fauci you know he said
something one of the comments i'll read
about what he said about
uh uh he said it's on page six let me
read this to you and i'll go to the
fountain side where he said the
desantis regrets not speaking out much
louder against trump's recommendation to
stay home this is a cnn story florida
governor desantis said one of the
biggest regrets in office was not
speaking out much later in march 2020
when uh former president donald trump
advised the nation to stay home to slow
the fast spread and coronavirus desantis
blame people like anthony fauci for
advising trump to consider a shutdown
fouchy the country's top infectious
disease expert was part of the
coronavirus response team that was led
by vice president mike pence and
included other public health experts but
the decision was trumps to make and
desantis ultimately followed the white
house lead closing florida schools
governing government buildings gyms bars
and restaurant dining rooms and advising
floridians to stay home so that's a
direct shot at trump and fauci but if if
governor desantis was the president
today if he was how how do you think he
would have handled faulchie what what
would that relationship with voucher be
would he been fired what would he have
done with fauci i'm curious
well you know hindsight is always 20 20.
so if we were looking back at march 2020
april 2020 during the very beginning of
covid when nobody really knew what this
virus would do or we didn't have any
information about it of course a lot of
politicians governor desantis included
they
made policies out of an abundance of
caution i think but i think what
desantis has done
which is unique for a politician to do
is he looked back on what happened in
april in the stay-at-home order for that
month and he said that was a mistake if
i had known then what i know now about
covid and about how it spreads and about
the risks i would not have issued that
order we would not have closed anything
no paul it's so rare to hear a
politician just admit that and so
stannis has ruled out any future
lockdowns even when we had a case surge
recently it's going down now but we did
have a surge with omicron like every
state had um and you know that was never
on the radar the idea of closing things
as far as your question about fauci in
particular well i want to back up the
interview that you're referring to where
trump where he mentioned um fauci and
you know cnn framed it as though it was
an attack on trump it wasn't he didn't
mention trump he mentioned
fauci by name and he clearly if you
listen to the context of that interview
on the ruthless podcast he clearly put
the blame on fouchy for this idea that
lockdowns would work to control the
spread and um you know i think though
let's say
you know
one day governor desantis is president
and fauci is still around and again like
i said i don't know what he's going to
do but
he would be 83 i mean so you know i mean
he seems like he's
if desantis was president he would be
83. he seems like he's still um
he's still
pretty energetic and obviously has a
huge role in the biden administration a
very negative role but he has a lot of
power so seems to um you know as old as
he is still has
he's still sharp um i would say as a
civil servant you're limited in terms of
what you can do in terms of firing civil
servants but i think there's a way to do
because fauci lied to congress we know
that like he testified to congress
something that wasn't true so that is a
reason
a legal reason to remove him from his
position
um if it were march 2020 before all of
that happened before the congressional
testimony before any of this
and you see that fauci is
an activist and he screwed up i mean
earlier with the aids crisis when hiv
first started like he had a long history
of basically failures and so if you know
that and you want to sideline him you
can sideline him
give him something to do that has
nothing to do with the coveted response
and work with people like scott atlas j
baracharya and these different doctors
who kind of are looking at the evidence
and have different ideas you know and so
i think trump did when he was president
he did actually try to seek out those
views but he was really being
pushed from all sides whether from
fouchy berks from the press from by from
so many people you know basically
blaming him unfairly i believe for all
the kova deaths that happened under his
presidency now we see biden biden's
presidency we've seen more people die
than died under trump nobody blames
biden directly for that and i don't
believe they should because i don't
believe that it's any president's fault
maybe the president of china i mean if
we want to blame somebody but like um
you know i so i think i wouldn't say
that anyone would get everything right
nobody's gotten everything right
throughout the entire pandemic but i do
think governor desantis approach is to
look at the data see what it's showing
him and make a decision based off of
that
if um
question for you said hindsight is 20
20. i think we can all agree that you
know
march of 20
you know march april that first initial
wave when we didn't know the hell was
going on people are wearing masks for
the first time ever
there's a different perspective now you
know hindsight is 20 20. um
so i think
i'll just read you a quote but it's
basically i'll just summarize it it's
not just a health crisis we're also
dealing with an economic crisis
businesses shutting down physical health
crisis mental health crisis we're
talking about like that like there's a
famous
quote that war is too important to be
left to just the generals so essentially
you know this pandemic is too important
to be left to just the scientists the
fouchies of the world so you need
businessmen and operators and
entrepreneurs who are saying well yeah
i get it shutting down might you know
stop the spread but what happens to all
these businesses what happens to people
sitting at home you know not exercising
not getting out so i essentially
ultimately my question is
if you can summarize desantis view of
how to handle covet in as few words as
possible
what would that be
keep people informed about the realities
about what the data says and let them
make their own decisions and respect
those i think you made a great point i
think
you know there was tunnel vision in this
country still is to some extent in some
places where people would just listen to
fauci or whichever of the doctors is on
cnn is saying that we need to do this
and that but they're not taking into
account the other effects about the
economy it's tied to health right if you
lose your job if you lose your business
your health deteriorates because of that
maybe not directly from injury
it's mental health kids who were locked
out of school for a year and a half are
now in places like california they're
now seeing spikes in psychiatric
impatience treatment for kids which is
so sad because kids are not at high risk
um you know of the buyer but they are at
high risk of depression they are at high
risk of suicide even like it's it's it's
so terrible that we didn't like a lot of
the
um scientific community mostly led by
fauci didn't really take this into
account they're focused on just covid
they don't think of the other health
risks um that are tied to the economy
that are tied to keeping things open and
living a normal life um and so i think
it's all about balance and governor
desantis believes that as well balancing
um all these different concerns economic
and health-wise to keep society
functioning and doing the least amount
of damage so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]